and your favorite musician 10 years ago.
I put mine up on the screen to help you along.
Now we asked people
to predict for us, to tell us
how much money they would pay right now
to see their current favorite musician
perform in concert 10 years from now,
and on average, people said they would pay
129 dollars for that ticket.
And yet, when we asked them how much they would pay
to see the person who was their favorite
10 years ago perform today,
they say only 80 dollars.
Now, in a perfectly rational world,
these should be the same number,
but we overpay for the opportunity
to indulge our current preferences
because we overestimate their stability.
Why does this happen? We're not entirely sure,
but it probably has to do
with the ease of remembering
versus the difficulty of imagining.
Most of us can remember who we were 10 years ago,
but we find it hard to imagine who we're going to be,
and then we mistakenly think that because it's hard to imagine,
it's not likely to happen.
Sorry, when people say "I can't imagine that,"
they're usually talking about their own lack of imagination,
and not about the unlikelihood
of the event that they're describing.
The bottom line is, time is a powerful force.
It transforms our preferences.
It reshapes our values.
It alters our personalities.
We seem to appreciate this fact,
but only in retrospect.
Only when we look backwards do we realize
how much change happens in a decade.
It's as if, for most of us,
the present is a magic time.
It's a watershed on the timeline.
It's the moment at which we finally
become ourselves.
Human beings are works in progress
that mistakenly think they're finished.
The person you are right now
is as transient, as fleeting and as temporary
as all the people you've ever been.
The one constant in our life is change.
Thank you.
(Applause)